[Music]  German and Tanzanian pupils have teamed  up to go green in Germany the students  of Bill Hema Harper school have plotted  5,500 trees and installed solar panels  on the roof allowing the school to  generate its own electricity but the  students want to share their passion  with others that's why they regularly  visit Bishop Moshe secondary school in  Tanzania together they planted another  500 trees in Tanzania and they also  installed solar panels on the school's  roof the Tanzanian students are now  preparing to visit their German  counterparts together they help the  environment while making lots of new  friends  [Music]  do you like that if you are also doing  your bit tell us about it  visit our website or send us a tweet  hashtag doing your bed we share your  stories  [Music]